THIRD AND
SPRINGING THROUGH CENTER.
A PARTIAL
SCORING STREAK WAS SNAPPED ON
SUNDAY.
FORSLING BACK AFTER IT AND
HUSTLING ON THE FORE-CHECK.
BOBSON.
NELSON BACK TO DOBSON.
BEAUVILLIER PUTS IT THROUGH KIL!
SEBASTIAN AHO ON THE DELAYEDAHO.
HE GOES, WHERE DID HE GO?
IN THE CORNER!
BEAUTIFUL SHOT BYEING A
GOAL SCORER.
HE IS PRETTY GOOD ON THE
WAITS.
WEEGAR ACROSS AND5 SECONDS.
GIROUX TO BARKOV.
LOOKING.
NET.
THE FAKE. CAREER
YEAR.
>> Alan: GIVING IT AWAY IS
GREENE.
DUG FREE BY DOBSON AND HE GETS
HIS FEET MOVING AND QUICKLY
BRAKES.
LEAP O OE
PERIOD.
>> Butch: THEY ARE ALLOWING
PANTHERS ON THE OUTSIDE HAD IT .
BACK BEHIND THE NET.
PALMIERI TO PAGEAU AND I
THAT.
THEY TRY TO TAKE THE LEAD ON THE
POWER PLAY.
BARZAL IN FRONT AND SCORE! PAGE
SAYS, I GOT THAT ONE. THE OTHER.
CIZIKAS THROUGH CENTER.
>> Butch: MA AT A
STANDSTILL AND MAYBE YOU CAN WIN
PAGEAU TRAILING THE PLAY.
GOOD PRESSURE HERE.
JOSH BAILEY STEALS IER IS SOROK!
HE CAN'T STANDING THERE
PLAYING GOAL.
FINISH AND TAKE SOMEBODY OUT OF
BOTH
BARKOV WITH TWO GOALS TONIGHT
WITH A COME F-FROM-BEHIND
WIN